bu Merhaba arkadaşlar Almanca kolay
hoşgeldiniz Ben Almanca öğretmeni Erhan
Özdemir dersimizin konusu değil ve Urfa
yani meslekler Hazırsanız dersimiz
başlasın arkadaşlar Büfe yani meslekler
incelendiğinde Almanca'da güzel
Türkçemiz den farklı olarak kadınlar ve
erkekler olmak üzere ikiye ayrılmış
durumda zaten bunu daha önceden de
söylemiştik eli de adı bilmediği dedi
shieldi Dolayısıyla Biz mesleklerde bu
şekilde görmüş oluyoruz Dolayısıyla
Dilerseniz mesleklere Bir bakalım
değerle Aha denildiğinde ki o ben
oluyorum erkek öğretmen kastedilmiş
oluyor Eğer bu Bir Kadın öğretmen sağ
arkadaşlar Dila Gazi'nin demem gerekiyor
farkettiyseniz arkadaşlar veya ve değil
diye iki ayrılmış durumda ancak
kadınlarda Demek ki artı olarak
sonlandırıcı
o gelmiş Dolayısıyla Kadın öğretmen
diyecek olursak değil yakın demem
gerekiyormuş demek ki erkeklerde
diğerleri Aha kadınlar daysa dile
haberim şeklinde yani Kadın öğretmen
şeklinde inceleniyor Muş değer Şule Evet
buraya baktığımızda diğer şu yla bu
öğrenci demek arkadaşlar erkek öğrenci
buradaki de suyla ilkokuldan lise dahil
öğrenci grubunu kapsıyor diğer sürüyor
katı kız öğrenci diyecek olursak
arkadaşlar değil Şöyle Özer'in demem
gerekiyor bakın Burada da tıpkı üste
olduğu gibi in takısı alıyor ve bunun
artık elindeymiş değil Dolayısıyla kız
öğrenci diyecek olursak bir şöyle hem
demem gerekiyormuş değil mi sonraki de
baktığımızda de Ya sudan Az önce bunun
ayrımına özellikle söyledi Çünkü diğer
sudan de arkadaşlar
bu gören yani üniversite öğrencisi Demek
ki de student üniversite öğrencisi ve bu
bir erkek öğrenci Dolayısıyla değer
sudan şeklinde anlıyormuş üniversite
öğrencisi Peki üniversite öğrencisi kısa
O zaman ne diyeceğiz değil sudan tır
bakın sonlandırıcı in Dolayısıyla
artikel ne olmuş bir bir sudan ten
şeklinde yorumlanmış sonrakine bakalım
arkadaşlar de ya Fiat koy ifade ve kafa
satıcı ya da esnaf da diyebiliriz buna
defa Demek ki satıcı ya da esnaf
anlamına gelmiş oluyor bu kadın esnaf
iyice bulursa defek alfazen şeklinde
yorumlanıyor bakın Burada da Gene ne
olmuş Yeni takısı 60 değil mi değer
pilot Bu da Anlaşılacağı üzere bir
medepia
ne demek ki erkek filot kadın pilot Eğer
değil pilotin demem gerekiyor demek ki
erkeklerde de pilot kadınlarda ise bir
pilotin şeklinde yorumlanıyor diğer
Vedat tüyo eve de Evet arkadaşlar diğer
feda tüyo yazı işlerinden sorumlu kişi
değil mi Diğer Vedat ya bu bir kadın
Yazı İşleri sorumlusu İsa Bir Veda
tiyazin şeklinde yorumlanıyor değer
geornalist diğer jurnalist Bu arkadaşlar
gazeteci anlamında Bu bir kadın gazeteci
ise bir zaman isterim şeklinde
yorumlanmış oluyor demek ki erkek
gazeteci diğer ucu analiz kadın gazeteci
ise değil ona Listenin şeklinde ne
oluyormuş yorumlanır olmuş de ya mesani
kavga edermiş Anık
bu başlar Bu da tamirci anlamına geliyor
yani mavi yakalı anlamında Diğer mesane
kabuğu bir kadın teknik teknik al ya da
tamirci ise kalmaya da Bu gayet olan
almaya da tır şoförü işte temizlik
işçisi çöpçü çöpçü gibi ki Türkiye'de bu
böyle Öyle değil mi mümkün dolayısıyla
da erkek tamirci ya da işte mekanikle
uğraşan mavi yakalı dediğimizde de
mesane cuir Bu bir kadın Sadi mesane
kafanı şeklinde yorumlanıyor Muş diğer
foto kafa Anlaşılacağı üzere fotoğrafçı
bu bir kadınsa değil foto Kafein
şeklinde yorumlanıyor Muş Bakın
arkadaşlar Demek ki buraya kadar hep
kadınlar da bir artık e Live in
sonlandırıcı alırken buraya bir bakalım
değer kahve kahve arkadaşlara
ne demek şimdi bu bir kadın s değil
dikkat edin arkadaşlar değil köşeye
Demek ki kadın aşçı diyecek olursak o
niye dönüşmüş şöyle dönüşmüş Dolayısıyla
değil Köse'nin şeklinde yorumlanmış
arkadaşlar buradaki öyle mutlaka ne
yapıyoruz dikkat ediyoruz Dilerseniz bu
öğrenmiş olduk larımızı Bir
tekrarlayalım Demek ki diyen değerliymiş
arkadaşlar gel ya ha erkek öğretmen bu
bir kadınsa dile Akademi Kadın öğretmen
size değil ya kadın demem gerekiyor
ilkokuldan lise dahil değil mi öğrenci
grupları bir öğrenci kast ediyorsa Eğer
diğer suyla demem gerekiyor Eğer bu bir
kız öğrenci ise bir şöyle hazırlayacağım
ve ki bu öğrenci bir üniversite
öğrencisi ise o zaman diğer sudan ama
erkek öğrenci değil mi Bu bir kız
öğrenci
bu ver seni ise ne diyecekmiş izdi şu
Dentin diyecek misiniz Diğer ve Kalfa
sanırım bunun için değil mi esnaf en
doğru en şey ısıtıcı anlamına da
girebiliyor en düz ifadeyle ancak esnaf
demek daha doğru Tabi yabancı dil
öğrenirken arkadaşlar güzel Türkçemizi
de sahip olalım değil mi Yani sahip
çıkılır Defne Kalfa Demek ki arkadaşlar
esnaf Bu bir kadın esnaf sadife kayıp
bakın şeklinde yorumlanmış oluyor Berat
pil out diplotene Bu da zaten anlaşılır
bilme pilot demekmiş diğer Vedat tüyo
yazı işlerinden sorumlu kişi değil mi
veda Sedat diyor bu bir kadınsa Eğer
değil Vedat ödemem gerekiyor diğer şu an
ALES bu gazeteci bir erkek değil mi Bu
bir kadın
ne giyse bir zor analistin demem
gerekiyor diğer mesane kaev tamirci
anlamında tabi Arkadaşlar bunu zamanla
diğer derslerde de görüyor olacağız
bunun başına sözgelimi de Altunmeşe
harika denildiğinde isterseniz bunu
şöyle ifade edebilirim buraya Eğer
kadrajı da giriyorsa Ben de Auto meşale
K dediğimde
iyi bakın bu şekilde ifade edildiğinde
araba teknisyeni yani bununla uğraşan
kişi kastedilmiş oluyor önüne Auto
gelmiş oluyor Dolayısıyla Biz spesifik
belli başlı bir meslekten bahsediyorsak
ve ooooo branşın teknisyeni ise ki bu
durumda araba teknisyeni değil mi
arabadan sorumlu teknisyen Demek ki de
Auto mesai kadiye karşımıza çıkıyor Peki
bu bir kadınsa bu işi yapan bir kadınsa
ozan ne olacak arkadaşlar diğer yerine
bir getirmiş olacağım Dolayısıyla Bu ne
olacak bu durumda da bir Altuğ mesani
kahvem diyeceğim bakın Burada da gene
aynı şekilde ne olmuş için gelmiş bir
Auto V Hani Kazan Umarım kadraja
girmiştir evet diye Auto mesai Demek ki
araba teknisyeni anlamına gelmiş oluyor
Ne yapmış olur
o spesifik bir şeyden bahsetmiş oluyordu
Evet Şimdi arkadaşlar burada diğer foto
Kabuğu da neydi fotoğrafçı demekti değil
foto Kafein Bu da kadın fotoğrafçı
dereko aşçı demiştik erkek Bu bir kadın
aşırı ise bir köşesinde demekmiş
Dilerseniz bu görmüş olduklarımızı doğru
telafi hızıyla tekrarlayalım gibi Urfa
biberi nfı Deliha Deliha dilya Gazi'nin
dili harfinin
3D similo de suyla iş suyla hınn miniş
ilahinin de student Desk student
bu diş bu devletin
bu iş dökersin
bu tefek tayfa
bu gevrek ayfa dikerek al-fatiha
o şifre karta hem
çok değerli load error fiload
bu ipi lutea bir pilot enine
bu yaz Vedat tüyo biraz elektroyu
O bir erkek Aferin
bu eder köye seni
3D juvenalis
3D Java list
bu Divan aliston Dijon aliston
ne demiş Hani k
bu dermiş Hani k
iyi bilmesi hangi kahveni demacia Hani
kahvenin
3D fotocasa
bu foto kafi bir foto Cafe derko
3D ka di köşe dikkat etsin
ve diğer Auto meşale k
ve diğer Auto mesani k16 o misali Cafe
Auto mesane kahvenin sıradaki
meselelerle devam edelim arkadaşlar diye
bekader Beka arkadaşlar fırıncı demek
yani bu ekmeklere lezzetli şeyleri yapan
yaklaşık 3000 çeşit ekmek yapılıyor
almaya arkadaşlar o anlamda bayağı
bayağı bir revaçta olan bir bir meslek
bu şimdi bu bir kadın fırıncı ise değil
be kahvenin demem gerekiyor demek ki de
Beka erkek fırıncı dibe kafesinde kadın
fırıncı demekmiş diğer Zena bu şarkıcı
demek arkadaşlar Demek ki erkek şarkıcı
de Zena kadın şarkıcı ise değil Zehra
Hem ne oluyor arkadaşlar Emin takısı
almış oluyor değil mi Diğer şarj pil
Odessa USB da aktör demek arkadaşlar
O şarj pil A bu bir sinema oyuncusu
olabileceği gibi bir tiyatro oyuncusu da
olabiliyor yaşamış biri olarak
adlandırılıyor bu bir kadın ve eğer bir
Çavuş pil Özer'in demem gerekiyor demek
ki Kadınlarda da ne oluyor değil ve
mutlaka in sonlandırıcı sını alması
gerekiyor diapolis sest Bu da
Anlaşılacağı üzere polis demek
arkadaşlar Demek ki erkek polis memuru
ise bu diğer politist verilmiş oluyor bu
bir kadın polise değil polisistin denmiş
oluyor Days aidat beyazı da asker demek
Arkadaşlar bu bir kadın asker s dizel da
then this oldu atın Demek ki kadın asker
anlamında ymış beğenince Niye ya Bakın
bu Fransa dan gelen bir kelime jelenia
buraya dikkat edelim diğerini jenya
ne Bu arkadaşlar mühendis demek bu bir
kadın mühendise bin jenya verin
birincinin yağın Demek ki kadın mühendis
anlamındadır de a stat de at Bu
arkadaşlar Doktor demek de at Doktor
demek Ancak buraya dikkat edelim
Arkadaşlar bir etten indi ettin Demek ki
kadın doktor iyi etsin diye
adlandırılıyor ve dikkat edin ama
üstünde un altımı Dolayısıyla Ee
şeklinde okunuyor diğer at erkek doktor
Kent kadın doktor Demek ki diğer etsin
diye adlandırılmış oluyor de an mcleod
de anvil o mu kat demek arkadaşlar bakın
Burada dikkat edelim Aa diye dönüşmüş
abone oldu almış Dolayısıyla kadın
Avukat diyecek olursak değil an ver
ama bir an Well then Demek ki kadın
Avukat her kek avukatları neymiş de ya
Android veya housman ve di household
görüyoruz diğer burada masyon isterseniz
diye House hava arkadaşlar ev hanımı
anlamına gelmiş oluyor değil Hava soğuk
bunu da karşılığı Erkek pek Evet evinde
Duran erkekler için değil mi bunun
içinde Demek ki de housman demem
gerekiyor demek ki ev hanımı değil House
ha erkeklerde ise ne demiş oluyoruz
değer housman demiş oluyoruz
ilk defa kankenist Liga Evet diğer kan
40 Liga hasta hemşir diyebiliriz
arkadaşlar bunun için yani Erkek Hemşire
hemşire bir de kalp flagg a Ancak bunun
kadınlardaki karşılığı yani hemşire
diyecek bulursak bir Kankanın flagga
verin demiş oluyoruz friga Aslında
bakıcı anlamında hasta bakıcı ve bir
Türkçede bu farklı anlama gelebiliyor
Yani bu sağlık eğitimi görmüş bir
profesyonel arkadaşlar ve dolayısıyla de
kalp flagga diye adlandırılıyor
kadınlarda bir Kanka üfle gazen diye ya
da bir kankanı schwesta İşte bu 11
arkadaşlar hemşire anlamına gelmiş
oluyor di kalkmış Vesta Dilerseniz şöyle
öğrenmiş olduk larımızı Bir toparlayalım
da
ve fırıncı değilmiş arkadaşlar de Adeka
ve bu bir erkekse Bu bir kadın fırıncı
ise değil be Kazın denmiş oluyor ve ne
oluyor kadınlarda arkadaşlar inta
kısalmış oluyor değil mi mesleklerde ve
mutlaka bir ile adlandırdığı değil mi o
meslek Bu bir şarkıcı erkek ise diğer
Zehra denmiş oluyor ve kadın şarkıcı ne
olmuş oluyor arkadaşlar değil Zehra
belirlenmiş oluyor diğer Savaş spila
bunu olacak arkadaşlar aktör erkek bir
Çavuş plağın kadın de polis siz erkek
polis bir polisistin kadın polis bez al
Dead asker erkek asker bilmeden normal
asker şeklinde Bu bir kadın asker sediz
ayda temizlenmiş oluyor diğer inceliyor
mühendis deyince ne haber kadınların bez
de at Dr
o kadın doktor da diyecek olursak bir
hayat sistemi şeklinde nitelem gerekiyor
bakın burası çok önemli a a Ümre orta
dönüşmüş buna mutlaka dikkat etmemiz
gerekiyor de en Mahallesi Avukat
buradaki a kadınlarda Ne oldu arkadaşlar
değil an Well then şeklinde yorumlanıyor
buradan devam ettiğimizde değil House
how neydi ev hanımı anlamında ydı Bu bir
erkekse mi diyeceğiz de ya housman
diyeceğiz de kalkmış Vega hasta bakıcı
Ama bu gene sağlıkçı anlamında
arkadaşlar on altını çizmekte fayda var
bunun eğitimini görmüş birisi Bu bir
kadınsa erdi kampüsleri gazlarin demiş
oluyorum ya da hemşire derken kendi
kalkmış Best da Deniz oluyorum Öyle
şimdi bu öğrenmiş olduk larımızı
Arkadaşlar doğru telafi hızıyla
söylemeden önce şunu da
Bu sayede var arkadaşlar Almanya'da
hangi mesleği yaparsanız yapın bu teknik
bir meslek olabilir bu bir sosyal meslek
olabilir Ne olursa olsun bunu mutlaka
eğitimini görmemiz gerekiyor Yani o
mesleğin sertifikasını diplomasını Her
neyse bunu almadan Siz bunu yapacak
olursanız cezalı duruma bile düşer
gidiyorsunuz Yani bu bir kalebodur
teknikerinden tutunda bir Badanacı bile
olabilir mutlaka bunun eğitimini almanız
gerekiyor ki bu mesleği yapabilirsiniz
Dilerseniz şimdi doğru telafi hızıyla bu
öğrenmiş olduklarımızın üzerinden
geçelim
ne demek a d k biber Taze biber Aferin
gez Ey na na de Zeyna bizden Aferin bize
yazın
bu Çavuş pillow
Ben de Çavuş Pizza Çavuş pilavın
bu Çavuş billahi
3D polis ses
Yok böyle ses
Bu bir polise sitelerinin bir polis
sitenin içinde Zaliha
3D zayd at this aidat in
ama biz ayda Team
ne deyince niye ya
o derin jenya
Sen bir incele yakın
ve bu İncirli yakın
3D a
Bu dermott bir String bir ettin diğer
Men White
ve diğer Android
şu an Word in indian Well then de
housman de houseman
en iyi House House
he he House Hav Der kanf Liga
bu Erkan fleka hadi kalpli galeri
ve Kamufle galeri
Bu bir kalkmış Vesta
Bu bir kalmış festo
Evet şimdi de Dilerseniz Arkadaşlar bu
öğrenmiş olduğumuz mesleklerle ilgili
karşımızdakinin Messi'nin e şekilde
sorarız kendi mesleğinizde Nasıl
söyleriz onu bir inceleyelim Şimdi
burada arkadaşlar basmanız ipi
hoofplates sorusunu görüyoruz Yani siz
mesleklerden yani meslek olarak nane
rica ediyorsunuz Ne yapıyorsunuz
anlamına geliyorsa bir türkçeleştirdiği
mizde mahalle ile yapmak demektir ve Uf
leste mesleki olarak gibi birebir güzel
Türkçe'ye çevirebiliriz Dolayısıyla
sizin Mesleğiniz nedir demiş oluyoruz
bakın Burada daha önceden de değilmiş
olduğum zibu Nezaket formu için geçerli
olan bir form bileziği ve üçüncü çoğul
grubunda çekimlenir hatırlayacak
olursanız burada arkadaşlar sizli bizli
bir konuşmada bilmesi
ve temiz nedir diye sorulduğunda Demek
ki basmak xihu Flash sorusunu soruyorum
Bu yeni tanıştığım birisi olabilir değil
mi Büyük olasılıkla Çünkü sizli bizli
bir konuşmayı gerektiriyor Bu arada onda
söylemekte fayda var arkadaşlar
Almanya'da bir Alman'la ya da bir
Almanca konuşan birisi ile bir araya
geldiğinizde bu sizli bizli konuşma bu
ya dönüşebiliyor Çünkü onlar da hani
samimiyetten oldukları için Zile
başlayan bir cümle duya dönüşebiliyor Bu
da Bilginiz dahilinde olsun Eğer ben
Senli Benli şekilde konuşuyorsam Senin
mesleğin nedir diye soracak olursan bu
durumda Was machst Tube bu Flash diye
soracak Dolayısıyla toparlayacak olursak
buraya Sizin Mesleğiniz nedir diye
sorduğumda ne diyor muşum basma hızlı
bir uflex Senin mesleğin nedir diye
sorduğumda ise
bu su bir Uf Les demem gerekiyor değilmi
ya da arkadaşlar basit bir Bu sizin
Mesleğiniz nedir dediğimizde Vasisi O
bir Uf demem gerekiyor Burada şimdi iyi
görüyoruz Arkadaşlar bu yapıları benim
senin onun bunları ilerleyen dersimizde
derslerimizde görüyor olacağız
Dolayısıyla bunu Şimdilik bir kılıf
olarak alalım arkadaşlar Break ki sizin
Mesleğiniz nedir diye sorduğumda bakın
burada Nezaket formu söz konusu olduğu
için iyi büyük harfle başlıyor
Dolayısıyla vasista ve bu sizin
Mesleğiniz nedir diyorum ama deseydim ki
ya da şu şekilde sorsaydım Senin
mesleğin nedir bu durumda was eder ve
hıh diyecektim değil mi Demek ki buraya
bir toparladığımız da sizin Mesleğiniz
nedir derken was Used
da bir Uf diye soruyorum Senin mesleğin
nedir diye sorduğumda İsa vs Diamond bir
uh diye soruyorum Evet sormuş oluyorum
şimdi de cevaplara gelelim arkadaşlar
Ben öğretmenim dediğimde eş benimle Aha
demiş oluyorum Ben öğretmenim Demek ki
eş bir la Ha ben öğretmen olarak
çalışıyorum dediğimde ise eş abartı alt
la demem gerekiyor abartın çalışmak
demek arkadaşlar öğretmen olarak
çalışıyorum dediğimde Demek ki iş abartı
alt la ha diyorum değil mi Dilerseniz
bunları bir toparlayalım arkadaşlar
Demek ki sizin Mesleğiniz nedir
dediğimde Vas mahzi bir Uf Les Deniz
oluyor değil mi Nezaket formu zi devreye
girdiğini Demek ki basmak zywoo Flash
sizi
o bilmesin nedir diye sorduğumda ise
basma su bir uflash diye sormam
gerekiyor alternatif olarak ne diyebilir
miyiz artık arkadaşlar was değiyor bir
bu ya dava xastime Wolfteam ve senin
dediğin de Daimi demiş oluyorum sizin
dediğinde ise bazen ya bir Oh sizin
Mesleğiniz nedir vermiş oluyorum Ben
öğretmenim dediğimde espirin levha demem
gerekiyor öğretmen olarak çalışıyorum
dediğimde ise eş abartı ait la demem
gerekiyor Dilerseniz bu öğrenmiş olduk
larımızı doğru telafi hızıyla
tekrarlayalım
iyi bakın video files
şimdi bakmanızı polis
Eğer bakmak Bu bir Bu kez
bu basma su bir yükle
bu vs diye bir bu
ama ben ses diye bir hu
Ya ben sistemde bu
bu ve Sisten bir Uğur
ve eşinle Aha işbirliği Ha ha ha eş
Abacı Aslı'ya ha iş amacı Aslı'ya ha
Bu bir dersimizin daha sonuna geldik
Arkadaşlar bu dersimizde değil bir Urfa
yani meslekler konusu görmüş olduk
ardından da karşımızdakinin mesleğini
sormayı ve kendime serimizi söylemeyi
görmüş olduk Bir sonraki dersimizde
görüşmek üzere diyorum hoşçakalın chüs